[Applause]
buildings collapsed lives destroyed
the extent of the damage in petrina and
surrounding villages is becoming
more clear as emergency workers search
for anyone who may still be buried
under the rubble the 6.4 magnitude
earthquake
struck on tuesday and was felt as far
away as vienna
and munich a series of strong
aftershocks
and the potential collapse of more
buildings have forced many to seek
shelter
outdoors
we live in a flat in petrina and a
building that's heavily damaged and it's
not safe anymore to be there
we have a camper van in the village we
spent the night in it
it's a bit better now because we have
electricity so we can stay
warm
we're very afraid it's chaos in the
house it's not destroyed but everything
is broken
all our stuff fell out of the cupboards
and was broken
we spent the night in the car but we
couldn't sleep at all
we have two children and i don't know
what to do
the towns of petrinia glena and sisak
were the hardest hit
some have returned to their homes to
find little more than debris
forced now to create makeshift shelters
from the bitter winter weather
the damage to infrastructure has made it
difficult to get help to those who need
it
this center has been set up to collect
and distribute food
water and other aid to those affected by
the earthquake
as the government urgently organizes
temporary shelter for those left
homeless
the army clears rubble and helps look
for survivors
this was the second earthquake in
croatia in two days
people here are fearful and in shock
the monumental task to rebuild lies
ahead
tanya novak al jazeera glina croatia